take it from there let me go through a
couple of facts to give you an update on
where we are today and then we'll take
your questions in terms of the numbers
of cases you see the curve continues to
go up
71 95 you see the number of people
tested continues to go up
this state is testing more people than
any state in the United States more per
capita than China or South Korea that is
a good thing we want to test we want to
find the positives and we want to find
the positive so we can isolate stop the
transmission we tested 14,000
people yesterday the number of cases
continues to go up 69 84 total number of
cases 66 thousand cases and those
numbers are daunting to be sure you see
it's continually continuing to move
across the state of New York there's
only one County now that does not have a
Kovac case anyone who says this
situation is a new york city only
situation is in a state of denial you
see this virus move across the state you
see the virus move across this nation
there is no American who is immune to
this virus I don't care if you live in
Kansas I don't care if you live in Texas
there is no American that is immune what
is happening to New York is not an
anomaly there's nothing about it a New
Yorkers immune system that is any
different than any other Americans
immune system so in many ways New York
is just a canary in the coalmine
what you see us going through here you
will see happening all across this
country so part of what we're doing here
is not only serving New Yorkers but we
believe that we're dealing with this
pandemic at a level intensity and
density that no one has seen before and
hopefully we'll learn lessons here
we can then share with people across
this nation terms of the overall numbers
66,000 have tested positive 9500 people
are currently hospitalized 2,000 ICU
patients 4000 patients are discharged
that's an increase of 632 you don't
often focus on this line when we have
these conversations but people go into
the hospital and people leave the
hospital and that's important to
remember we've dealt with some really
deadly viruses before we dealt with the
Ebola virus that's not what this is most
people will get sick most people will
get sick and stay home and have some
symptoms that's 80% by 20% we'll get
sick need hospitalization they'll feel
better and they'll leave it tends to be
those people who are acutely ill have an
underlying illness who have the most
most problems most impacted States New
York you see is at 66,000 New Jersey is
next to a 13 California 6,000 so we have
10 times the problem that California is
dealing with 2739 deaths in the state of
New York
total of 148 thousand cases 2739 deaths
that's a lot of loss it's a lot of pain
it's a lot of Tears that's a lot of
grief that people all across the state
are feeling 1200 is up from 965 deaths
yesterday what you're seeing is people
who have been ventilated been on
ventilators for a long period of time
the longer you're on a ventilator the
less likely you will ever come off that
ventilator and as we have now some
period of time when people first entered
the hospital and
first intubated we're seeing that death
number go up as the length of time on
the ventilator increases to keep it in
perspective that Johns Hopkins numbers
are still instructive we've been
studying this since China so seven
hundred and thirty two deaths thirty
four thousand worldwide total
hospitalized we're still looking for a
pattern on these cases that are coming
in we're still looking for a pattern in
the data the number goes up and number
goes down there's no doubt that the
number is still increasing there's also
no doubt that the rate has slowed we had
a doubling of cases every two days then
a doubling every three days then a
doubling every four days then every five
we now have a doubling of cases every
six days so while the overall numbers
going up the rate of doubling is
actually down the daily intubation rate
is way up again sometimes it's just an
anomaly there's no clear pattern as you
can see from those past several nights
discharge rate again that by and large
is going up people come into the
hospital they stay for a period of time
number of days and then they move on but
big picture as the situation is
painfully clear now there's no question
what we're dealing with there's no
question as to the consequences there's
no question as to the grief and the loss
of life and there's no question about
what we must do there are only two
missions there are only two operations
that we need to perform first the public
has to be responsible stay at home when
I issued the stay at home order it
wasn't it would be nice
if you did it is a mandate stay at home
if you're a non-essential workers stay
at home if you leave the house you're
exposing yourself to danger if you leave
the house you're exposing others to
danger you can get infected go home and
in fact whoever is at home so stay at
home I know the isolation can be boring
and oppressive it is better than the
alternative life is options right stay
at home that is the best option if you
are out
no proximity six-feet distancing you
don't want proximity to other people
and you want to stay away from places
that are dense still in New York City
you have too many places with too much
density I mean I don't know how many
different ways to make the same point
New York City parks
we made the point there's too much
density you want to go to the park go to
the park but not in a dense area not in
playgrounds where you're playing
basketball with other people and I have
said that New York City is trying to
reduce the density in those playgrounds
thus far they have not been successful
if that continues we'll take a mandatory
action to close down playgrounds as
harsh as that sounds but it can actually
save people's lives so that's mission
one mission two and this is going to be
more and more clear as we go on the
front line battle is in the health care
system the frontline battle is going to
be hospitals across the city across the
state and across this nation that is
where this battle is fought it's that
simple you know exactly where it's
coming you know exactly where the enemy
is going to attack
they're going to infect a large number
of people that number of people descend
on the healthcare system the healthcare
system can't deal with that number of
people you overwhelmed the healthcare
system that is what's happening so first
step was flatten the curve reduce the
density keep people home we've done
everything that we can possibly do there
second step is don't let the hospital
system get overwhelmed the soldiers in
this fight are our health care
professionals it's the doctors it's the
nurses it's the people who are working
in the hospitals it's the aides
they are the soldiers who are fighting
this battle for us you know the
expression save our troops troops quote
unquote
in this battle the troops are healthcare
professionals those are the troops who
are fighting this battle for us we need
to recruit more health care workers we
need to share healthcare professionals
within this state and within this
country as governor of New York I am
asking healthcare professionals across
the country if you don't have a
healthcare crisis in your community
please come help us in New York now we
need relief we need relief for nurses
who are working 12-hour shifts one after
the other after the other we need relief
for doctors we need relief for
attendants so if you're not busy
come help us please and we will return
the favor
we will return the favor New York yes we
have it now intensely there will be a
curve New York at one point will be on
the other side of the curve and then
there will be an intense
you somewhere else in the nation and the
New York way is to be helpful so help
New York
we're the ones who were hit now that's
today
but tomorrow it's going to be somewhere
else whether it's Detroit whether it's
New Orleans it will work its way across
the country and this is the time for us
to help one another we need supplies
desperately and we're working on that we
just had a very good meeting where we
discussed supplies I want to thank
Michael Evans from Alibaba who's here
with us today I want to thank Elizabeth
Jennings from the Asia Society who's
here with us today who are helping us
source supplies because we're in a
situation where you have 50 states all
competing for supplies the federal
government is now also competing for
supplies private hospitals are also
competing for supplies so we have
created a situation where you literally
have hundreds of entities looking to buy
the same exact materials basically from
the same place which is China ironically
enough and we're fighting amongst
ourselves we're competing amongst
ourselves we're driving the prices up
when we started buying ventilators they
were under $20,000 the ventilators are
now over $50,000 if you can find them
the ventilators didn't change that much
in two weeks the prices went up because
literally we are driving the prices up
but we need to give our frontline our
healthcare professionals the supplies
they need and we need to do it now our
rule here in New York has been planned
forward to get ahead of the problem the
old expression is don't fight the last
battle this virus has been ahead of
from day one we have been playing
catch-up from day one you never win
playing catch-up get ahead of the
problem
don't fight today's fight plan for two
weeks three weeks four weeks from now
when you're going to have the apex and
make sure that we're in a position to
win the battle when the battle is truly
drawn which is going to be at the apex
that's where why we are preparing
stockpiles now we're building a
stockpile the word stockpile by
definition means not for immediate use
it means you're preparing for a battle
to come and you have to have the
equipment and you have to have it now
I've done disaster work all across the
nation I can tell you this if you wait
to prepare for the storm to hit it is
too late my friends you have to prepare
before the storm hits and in this case
the storm is when you hit that high
point when you hit that apex how do you
know when you're going to get there you
don't there is no crystal ball but there
is science and there is data and there
are health professionals who have
studied this virus and its progress
since China we now have months of data
listen to the scientists listen to the
mental health the health care
professionals and follow the data and
that's what we're doing here in New York
we just had a great meeting where we
brought the healthcare system from
across the state of New York together
to come up with one coordinated plan not
private hospitals in public hospitals
not New York City hospitals and Long
Island hospitals in Westchester
hospitals in upstate hospitals not big
hospitals and small hospitals the entire
healthcare system
convened coordinated working as one for
the first time in decades no one can
ever remember the way we have deployed
and coordinated like this why because
this is a statewide battle and we want
to make sure that we are all coordinated
and we are all working together and
that's exactly what we've accomplished
at this meeting no politics no
partisanship no division there is no
time for that not in this state not in
this nation this is a deadly serious
situation and frankly it's more
important than politics and it's more
important than partisanship and if there
is division at this time the virus will
defeat us if there was ever a moment for
unity this my friends is the moment in
this situation there are no red states
and there are no blue states and there
are no red casualties and there are no
blue casualties it's red white and blue
this virus doesn't discriminate it
attacks everyone and it attacks
everywhere the president said this is a
war I agree with that this is a war then
let's act that way and let's act that
way now and let's show a commonality and
a mutuality and a unity that this
country hasn't seen in decades because
the Lord knows we needed today more than
ever before questions comments
yeah the question is that the president
suggested that PPE equipment may be
going out the back door first there is a
warehouse in Edison New Jersey it's the
New York City warehouse we are creating
a stockpile for someone to say well the
warehouse has equipment in it you should
be using that equipment today that
defies the basic concept of planning and
the basic operation that we have to have
working not just in this state but of
course the country if you are not
preparing for the apex and for the High
Point you are missing the entire point
of the operation
it is a fundamental blunder to only
prepare for today that's why in some
ways we are where we are
we've been at behind this virus from day
one you have the scientists and the data
projections showing you a curve the
curve goes like this you're over here
prepare for the high point of the curve
and do it now when you do it the night
before what am I going to tell the
hospitals when they call up and they say
we just had an influx of 50 percent more
people and we need more equipment and we
need more ventilators sorry so the whole
stockpile concept is to prepare for the
future in terms of a suggestion that the
PPE equipment is not going to a correct
place I don't know what that means I
don't know what he's trying to say if he
wants to make an accusation then let him
make an accusation
but I don't know what he's trying to say
by inference the we just had a
conversation about exactly that in New
York City there are basically two
systems there's what's called the
Greater New York Hospital Association
Ken raske represents it it's basically
the private voluntary hospitals Mount
Sinai Columbia etc then there's the
Health and Hospitals corporation which
are the public hospitals you have those
two systems we just discussed that those
two systems have to in this situation
undertake a balancing that they probably
have never had to do before in other
words you have eleven public hospitals
one Hospital starts to get overrun
there's a high load in one hospital
before that happens
transfer people to one of the hospitals
that has more vacancies and less load
distribute the load among those public
hospitals and do it immediately do it on
a daily basis one Hospital is starting
to overload distribute transfer same
thing with the Greater New York Hospital
Association and then we said take it a
step further
once one system is near capacity then
the two systems will work together to
share the load and we just discussed
that and we all agree to do it there are
no legal there are no legal barriers if
a hospital let's stay with the public
system because the public system I think
is going to face the greatest stress if
a public hospital starts to get
overloaded transfer to another hospital
with less of a load I don't believe
there are any restrictions Ken raske who
is the expert on this I would ask him to
chairman question we're gonna work is
one cohesive family system throughout
New York and the New York has been is
beyond the city itself including the
downstate area of both the island as
well as Westchester and and I think what
we're going to see is that balancing
that the governor is talking about
balance within the system balance went
without the system beyond it as we go
forward with the as we encounter more
and more stress with each day that goes
on the stress points will increase and
and as a result that balancing is
absolutely essential and because of the
because of the leadership of the
governor it is clear to everybody that
we are going to be one cohesive family
in tackling this
yeah
yeah yeah let me let me we just spent a
couple of hours doing it and it's
complicated but let me give you the top
line if I might the right now basically
the hospital systems operators basically
separate systems you have the public
hospitals you have the Greater New York
Hospital if you have Westchester
hospitals you have Long Island hospitals
and then you have upstate hospitals and
they have their own trade associations
and public a public and then the
privates of the privates we said we have
to work as one system so share staff
share resources if one Hospital is
doesn't have enough masks rather than
that Hospital have to scramble let the
other hospitals help more mutual Ken's
word is a good one a health care family
as opposed to these distinct operations
and we work that through to add on top
of the state system you then have now
Javits this facility 2,500 beds and the
comfort the ship that the president sent
1,000 beds these 2,500 beds of Javits in
the 1,000 beds of Kovac at comfort on
non kovat beds the federal government I
asked them to make the facilities covet
facilities they want to handle non kovat
people at Javits and comfort which means
their function will be basically an
overflow valve for existing hospitals
they can't take Kovac patients but they
can take non kovat patients when we talk
about a hospital getting near capacity
they could then download if you will to
Javits and the comfort
yeah how many years have you known me
the question is am i unwilling to tangle
with the present how many years would
you say you know me I twenty years have
you ever known a time in the 20 years
that I am unwilling to tang I'm a
tangler look I understand what the
president said about the first I think
he was I thank the president because I
take his comment as a compliment
the president can't commented on a poll
that said people were pleased with my
leadership and I thank him for that that
was a compliment as far as the
president's comment about having a
political contest with me I am not
engaging the president in politics my
only goal is to engage the president in
partnership this is no time for politics
and you know lead by example I'm not
going to get into a political dispute
with the president
I'm not going to rise to the bait of a
political challenge I'm not running for
president I was never running for
president I said from day one I wasn't
running for president and I'm not
running for president now I'm not
playing politics
I just want partnership to deal with
this and I said to the president quite
clearly look when you do good things for
my state and you're a good partner I
will be the first one to say you're a
good partner and I have I went to the
ship Comfort today I said thank you mr.
president we opened up this Javits
Center I said thank you to the army they
did a great job here the Army Corps of
engineer you do when you help my state
I'll say thank you if I believe that New
York is not being served the federal
legislation that they passed I will say
that to you
no sometimes it's simple just tell the
truth right and that's where we are tell
the truth if you're doing the right
thing by New York I'll say if he's doing
the wrong thing by New York or the rest
of the country I'll say it but I'm not
going to engage in politics not people's
I'm unwilling to tangle but because I
think it's inappropriate and I think
it's counterproductive and I think it's
anti-american forget the politics forget
the politics we have a national crisis
we are at war there is no politics there
is no red in blue it's red white and
blue so let's get over it and again lead
by example
[Music]
well we've we have said that no one can
get evicted for non-payment of rent and
that to me is the fundamental answer
right that solves all of the above you
can't pay the rent a lot of people can't
pay the rent they're not working there's
no income I can't pay the rent
landlord technically legally had a right
to say okay you're evicted we said I
said by executive order there can be no
evictions period if you pay the security
deposit you don't pay the security
deposit you pay part of the rent and
none of the rent you can't be evicted
for three months period if they want to
pay they can pay yeah again I think our
policy answers it you cannot be evicted
for non-payment of rent it's not that
you don't it's not that you won't go
rent at one time right because you
signed the contract and even the people
to whom you pay the rent have to pay the
rent right and they have expenses so no
evictions for non-payment of rent and
then we'll see where we are and we'll
see how long this goes on yes sir
yeah but we spoke about that today
Elmhurst Hospital is a New York City
public hospital we talked about the
health and hospital Corporation it's one
of the New York City public hospitals it
is struggling that's clear to everyone
and we spoke about it directly in this
meeting and I've asked other hospitals
to pitch in and help Elmhurst and
they've agreed and to also anticipate
other public hospitals that may struggle
as the numbers continue to increase and
be ready to help them also
you know we 100 to 200,000 White House
estimates 100 to 200 thousand as a death
toll
we don't have projections in this state
as to numbers of deaths we're studying
models which by the way you're done by
very professional companies I don't come
up with these models we have Cornell
while working on McKinsey working on at
the Bill Gates Foundation has an
institute that does projections we are
studying the projections to see how we
best deploy to make sure we're ready for
the next battle make sure we're ready
for the apex is 100,000 is it 200,000
look does it then whatever the number is
it's going to be staggering
the number is already staggering all
human life is a human life we've lost
over 1,000 New Yorkers to me we're
beyond staggering already we've reached
staggering and the only only point now
is do everything you can to save every
life possible that's what this is all
about
yeah right now a hospital this is my
opinion a hospital is basically an
isolated entity right one Hospital has
its own employees has its own logo has
its own finances does its own purchasing
has its staff you then have associations
of hospitals and then you have the
public New York City public hospitals
which are one system but still
individual hospitals that doesn't work
in this environment it just doesn't work
no one Hospital has the resources to
handle this no one Hospital can do its
own procurement no one Hospital has
enough staff no one Hospital can deal
with the capacity there has to be a
totally different operating paradigm
where all those different hospitals
operated on as one system so when I run
out of masks I can call brother Ken at
the other Hospital say I'm out of masks
can you send me some masks when I refill
I'll send them back we have to get to a
point where I can say I have too many
people walking in the door I can't
handle it and we are going to set a load
threshold so that when you get near that
load threshold you can send people to
other hospitals that have a lower
vacancy rate purchased together use
staff together
download patients together balance the
load and do it all across the state look
we have hospitals upstate New York that
are experiencing none of this where they
have staff capacity they have bed
capacity we need you now
here in this fight and engaged and
that's a totally different concept but
that's what we did today can you want to
come
to the question what what we're going to
do is work very cohesively with the
state government and the Department of
Health particularly in putting together
a command center that will receive all
this information on an instantaneous
basis and then begin feeding out that
information and instructions as to what
to do for example just simply in
discharging patients to this facility
this huge facility that that has been
built by our colleagues here that this
is this will create a way of decanting
the pressure on our institutions and and
that information will go to a central
place and transfers will be made and
that is part of this cohesiveness that
we're talking about the same thing
applies to supplies ventilators and all
the other stuff that goes into making a
hospital work this is going to be done
and we're - we're now in the process of
pulling it off in a complete basis
tomorrow yeah it's it's it's in the
works we're held up it will do central
purchasing central stockpile rather than
everyone have their own stockpile and
then distribute by need we'll take one
more all the way in the back
you know
the doctors are exactly right
the message is god bless you and thank
you we all applaud you we are in awe of
you we're all inspired by you
we all wonder secretly would we have the
courage to really step up at a time of
challenge and they are doing it and they
are doing it every day and we are all in
their debt and we respect them and we
love them for what they're doing and
they should have every piece of
equipment that they need to do their job
that is the least that we can do and we
are all doing everything we can to make
that a reality
thank you guys let's go to work okay